[Music]
now once again the democrats impeachment
obsession is completely backfired on
capitol hill because as we
shown you earlier tonight democrats
violent reckless rhetoric over the last
four years
it violates their own standards they
themselves would be guilty of inciting
insurrection and furthermore the only
way the democrats can make their case
against
donald trump is to deceptively as they
have been
editing his remarks and lying about what
he actually said on
january 6th this impeachment trial is
devoid of facts
it's devoid of any compelling evidence
devoid of any
constitutional basis here to react to
all of it south carolina senator lindsey
graham
and if you compare the words that we
played of stacey abrams and
hillary clinton and you intersperse the
comments of the managers
with the with the insurrectionist
language of the left
guess what it suits perfectly it fits
perfectly doesn't it
yeah i hope the defense team is watching
your show but let me tell your viewers
the not guilty vote is growing after
today
i think most republicans found the
presentation by the house managers
offensive and absurd we all know what
happened in the capitol was terrible
i hope everybody involved that broke
into the capital goes to jail
but i don't remember any of these house
managers saying a damn thing
when they were trying to break into my
house and going after susan collins and
spitting on all of us
if this is a problem for a politician to
give the speech that president trump did
well then kamala harris has a real
problem because she actively
engaged in bailing out writers and
here's what i would suggest
if you're a politician trying to raise
bail for people accused of writing
you're inciting more riots but here's
something nobody's talking about this
important if there if there was
pre-planning
uh there is no incitement do you agree
with that
yes sir that you're asking
okay so here's what the managers did
that yeah i'm asking you but
this is people said i didn't pay
attention today they're wrong
the managers have got this cockamania
idea
absurd theory that donald trump was
monitoring
the proud boys website and other
far-right websites and that he and dan
scovino
knew this was going to happen and they
encouraged it
that is looney tunes and you know why
they're saying that
because if the president didn't know and
it was actually
pre-planned he's not guilty so for the
first time today they're trying to
create a story line
that donald trump was in on it before it
happened
that he was monitoring the proud boys
and other crazy websites
and he knew they were going to come to
washington and with violence on their
mind
and he encouraged it that is beyond
bizarre this is not
evidence this is a liberal democratic
novel being presented as evidence
yeah you know and and i'm i'm watching
all of this and applying the language
and the standards that the democrats are
using in this case now they're saying
that the president challenging election
results
hillary clinton still never accepted to
this day
that she lost to donald trump same with
stacey abrams down in georgia
the reason i think and you tell me if
i'm wrong that they have to go
backwards to lay the foundation is
because the exact words of the president
uh did not incite violence nor did
anybody ever know
now now that we know that people were
plotting planning scheming
steeper than that go ahead you go can i
say something right quick
you bet new evidence makes you do that
the only reason they're trying to create
this bizarre storyline
that trump was in on it along with dan
scavino
is that we now know after impeachment
that was done without a lawyer without a
hearing without any witnesses
that the fbi and the capitol hill police
actually now
understand this was pre-planned they
were
planting bombs the night before so the
whole story line that donald trump calls
this by his speech
has fallen apart due to good law
enforcement activity
and here's what i want to know what did
nancy pelosi know and when did she know
it
episode was widely known by the fbi and
capitol hill police
that people were planning to come to
washington before the sixth
to create violence i want to know did
she know about that
the whole storyline originally was trump
created this from a speech
now we know the people had this on their
mind before he ever spoke
so they're playing this bizarre game of
trying to get trump
in on it before january the 6th this is
why you don't want to have snap
impeachments
evidence really does matter well
evidence matters big time because it's
now coming in
all right now walk us through the rest
of the process
here because you get 16 hours the
to prosecute the case the president's
lawyers right
they don't need 16 hours i think they
should do it in two three
four max um walker syrup
what happens okay okay so here's what i
would do i take all your videos
i mean literally you've got democratic
politicians being silent or encouraging
uh acts of violence i mean you've got
the sitting vice president when she was
a u.s senator
telling people they're not going to stop
they shouldn't stop and trying to bail
them out
so if i were the trump team i would
expose the hypocrisy here
and i would go after the argument that
it was pre-planned
and the idea that the president was in
on it is absurd
this thing is collapsing before their
eyes and the not guilty vote is growing
so it'll be over by sunday i hope for
the good country
the constitutional argument it was
pre-planned meaning he couldn't have
incited it
and the insurrectionist language of the
left not that complicated
lindsey graham